all right new controversy swirling
around the Biden family after Elon Musk
released internal Twitter files on the
company's suppression of the hunter
Biden laptop story Dr Carlson digging
deep into this and the family's finances
in a brand new Tucker Carlson Originals
Biden Inc part one is streaming now on
Fox Nation here's a little preview
Schweitzer and his team had a
breakthrough when they got access to a
copy of Hunter Biden's laptop we took
the laptop and we actually compared it
to publicly known sources of information
the Secret Service had released Hunter
Biden's Secret Service travel records at
the request of the U.S Senate so we took
the laptop mentions of trips and travel
compared to the Secret Service travel
logs they lined up completely 100
percent it was impossible that the
laptop was fake we identified four
businessmen in the laptop all four of
those businessmen have links to the
highest levels of Chinese intelligence
so there's a priest before you and
Tucker joins us now on the five it's
good to have you there's lots of
questions here so I'm going to kick it
around the table we'll start with Greg
for a question all right I I was going
to ask you what's on your on your
Originals that's not on Fox but I I was
I'm more interested in the fact that
you've lived in DC for a long a long
time you had lived there you ran into
Hunter
what what you you must have had some
relate not relationship but some kind of
interactions with them what would you
how would you characterize him in your
capacity
well I knew him really well
um and I always liked him I mean he's my
neighbor and friend and had dinner with
him a bunch I mean I knew him we talked
a lot about drinking I don't drink he
was struggling with that um but in the
background I knew and I knew people who
worked with him in his business that he
was effectively selling access to his
dad yeah and I'll just be totally honest
about it I never really thought about it
because I lived in DC for 35 years where
people sell access to government
officials they're called lobbyists and
that's kind of the business of the city
and I never really
thought wow that's kind of a crime
though I knew and I didn't know the
extent of it of course but I remember
someone who had worked with him saying
to me wow he's getting really really
close to you know what you should not be
doing because it's criminal and it turns
out based on what we know now from the
laptop that it was absolutely criminal
that his and the reason we made this
documentary was not to inform you that
he was doing something wrong everyone
knows that it was to take a long form
piece and explain it and show on the
screen exactly how we know this it's not
a partisan attack it's not attacking the
president's son this guy shared a bank
account with his dad while his dad was
the vice president his dad was bringing
him on trips including to China he was
doing business with the people he met on
those government trips and kicking back
the money to his dad that's not an
allegation that is shown on the laptop
which is why they suppressed it judge do
you have a question for Tucker you know
Tucker the frustrating part of all of
this and I'm just curious as to where
you think this all goes is it the first
amendment is being pooh-pooed now that
this has been it's out there and Elon
Musk is disclosed it through Matt taibi
they're like oh this is old news this is
no big deal I mean where is this country
going with respect to the first
amendment when it it's it's politically
instigated there was a presidential
campaign that was instigating censorship
from the against the American people
well of course I mean you're you're the
judge you know much better than I is a
legal matter private companies arguably
have a right to do with it what they
want with information the government may
not under the Bill of Rights the First
Amendment to the Bill of Rights may not
censor information political information
in particular and that's exactly what
you had here we have seen evidence proof
of the fact that the FBI and then the
Biden campaign and now the Biden
Administration pressures social media
companies Twitter in this case to
withhold relevant facts from the public
on the basis of which people might cast
their votes so that's not an attack on
Democracy I don't know how we're
defining attack on Democracy you can't
have a democracy without the free flow
of information if I don't know the facts
about the candidates I can't vote for
them in an informed way I can't have a
democracy and they prevented
the rest of us from knowing things they
did it in secret and once again they did
it illegally in contravention in the
First Amendment it could not be clearer
Geraldo Tucker hi so uh do you have an
opinion on whether or not this
information had it been known would have
affected the result of the election and
if you think it would have changed the
result of the election do you do you
think that President Trump was on to
something when he suggested that maybe
we have to suspend all the rules and
regulations including the Constitution
because it was such a colossal fraud
well one thing I learned Geraldo in the
midterms two weeks ago is I'm really not
good at predicting political outcomes at
all
I'm never doing that again either
looking ahead or retrospectively I'm
never going to tell you what might have
happened or what may happen ever again
because I'm bad at it but I will say as
a matter of principle and law you are
not allowed to censor information if
you're a government official and you had
the FBI meeting with Twitter and with
Facebook and lying telling those two
social media companies likely Google too
that this laptop they believed was
Russian well they had the laptop so they
knew in point of fact that it was not
they lied they're continuing to lie in
fact the former general counsel the FBI
became the general counsel at Twitter
Jim Baker We just learned about 25
minutes ago was censoring even on Friday
the release of internal Twitter
documents Elon Musk just fired him you
know an hour ago but we have a problem
with federal law enforcement with the
FBI oh yeah and we need to fix it Jesse
so the CIA and the FBI knows all about
Biden Inc and they've known about it for
years so why do you think the FBI and
the CIA want Joe Biden to be president
what that is such a deep question that I
can't answer I have all kinds of
suspicions it's obviously better to have
someone you can control and we've seen
this with previous U.S presidents
including Richard Nixon tapes just came
out showing this here's what we do know
at the very same time that they have
allowed Hunter Biden to skate on Pharaoh
violations he was representing foreign
governments he didn't register under the
foreign agent registration act Farah
they're going after some of the most
prominent Republicans in America on
pharah threatening them or indicting
them they threatened Rudy Giuliani right
they threatened Steve Nguyen one of the
biggest Democratic donors just yesterday
they indicted David Rivera a republican
office holder in Florida on a fair
violation no one's ever been indicted
under Farah in 60 years they have an
indicted Hunter Biden this whole laptop
is one big Fair violation how can they
do that this boggles the mind you don't
have to be a Republican or a trump
supporter or conservative you just have
to be an American who wants equal
treatment under the law to see this as
really scary
all right Tucker thanks for giving us so
much of your time and we'll watch
tonight and of course you can see bite
and ink available on Fox Nation now hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now